okay
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
uh
so okay so the question
is uh what brings him down
some people do and some people here
today were doing it like this
um
but this is too exposed
and uh you just see don't expose your
armpit area the place where your armor
is not
there you don't expose it even in modern
law enforcement
we don't stand in weaver stance anymore
because there's no armor there
you're always like this okay so you
don't open the armpits
so that can't be right
also things that are done
in a yin-yang universe are done
incrementally
not all at once so that can't be right
okay
and also
uh
[Music]
things
that are done in a yin-yang world
are done in harmony
with yiddiyam so i wouldn't be pulling
against his standing base
okay
i need him to be lowering
in some way that i would then continue
his load
does that make sense
so you wouldn't ever you would never do
this technique like this
that wouldn't work
okay
so
let's first
i think because it's so simple
let's identify
where he first
lowers himself because i need to extend
i need to lower him you just reverse
engineer that i need to lower him then i
need to extend his lower and lowering
energy
then he must be lowering himself prior
to that let's find out
where he first lowers himself
when he comes from the graph so don't
stick your hands up here because this is
not good
okay
um
so whatever i do
is going to be in conjunction
with his reaching for my house does that
make sense okay
then let's go back and let's look at the
handwork
okay
um
i have
i have giddon
chewed on
um
it again does not make sense that i have
three things
i have one thing
but those are phases amongst that one
thing
so if i was
combining
my outward spiral do you see it
with my
inward spiral and i do a movement like
this you see
so i go get on
that's how i always been you never you
never go to joe dawn like this
is jordan doesn't start down here get on
do you see hey you would never go to
gone like that
you have to pass through
chudan
then
do you understand
you guys understand okay
so
here
i'm doing chuda
jordan
we did yesterday
just like i have to chew down and get to
joedon do you understand
so
and the technique we just saw
demonstrated
this was the
shoot on hand
doing the chew
movement
that's not right
let's look at what it does to him and i
am pulling him
against his fingers
but if i start with
jeddah
i'm coiling him around my grip
do you understand that
okay not here
we're going to be
and that's how i bring it down
you see then when it comes to my center
line
that's where i turn it back over
and do this
[Applause]
i don't want to pull him and cut this
off
i want to coil slow i'm going to coil
him
gets to my center line i don't know
about two hands
me in kitchen
and spread
and chew gum
foil
centerline
pull
almost ready
so yesterday
but today get done
okay
they're done
[Music]
so just answering the question
how does he come down
okay
okay so the question is
how do i get up
uh
from cutting the hand off
to the hard part
or to the head
okay
um let's go over get on again
if you hold my
four corners still
this uh dual movement
i'm sorry jonah
this dual movement is going to
look like this
chew right
all right
and
get done
okay
but it looks like my hands are going out
away from each other do you understand
but
when
when i start the movement
when bringing my hands together
it's when i stay here that my hands
start to go out
but in the midst of bringing my hands
from together to out i start to turn
right
although my hands look like they're
going out
there's going to be an inwardness to
them okay
let's just keep that in mind
a way to reverse engineer
all of this testovaki is i'm gonna i'm
gonna do this powder i'm gonna do this
powder i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna do that powder
but i'm gonna find his neck
i'm going to find an imi nugget
and i'm going to find the back of this
person
in the technique
so between these two
guide posts my body will learn when and
how to move
because i don't change my arms
i change my body i can do that
i can change my timing
i can do that okay
so
i know my body
is going to come down
and do this
but i know i have to end up
here
so i do my arm pattern
and
i do it when
and with
the foot maneuver that allows me to get
to the back oh the
the guide rail of the hand pattern
is going to teach me
the tempo
and how to walk how to move how to get
to the back okay
what would what would the contrary be
over here
you see i if you look at it and you
start plotting that
geometrically on a grid
he's coming at me i get out of the way i
click i clear the line of attack i get
to the side you see
and then
i lead him to the inside as i go to the
outside
and then
i pull him around
almost like a
shot clip
okay i generate centrifugal energy
uh with this centripetal energy
okay
but what we're going to do instead
instead is i'm just doing
my power okay
my arms are going to open
and i'm going to move
so that it touches his neck
what does that mean so that the next
inward spiral is in the right place for
the position that's how i move okay
let me move without the next inward
spiral to be in its place okay
so
that's not gonna be an inner spiral now
i'm gonna have to pull
i know my arm from here
is going to go
boom
right into the inner spiral
huh
so look if you look here
it's not where it needs to be so i have
to move
so that it can be
where it needs to be
i don't chase him with my hands my hands
do the pattern i move my body so that
that pattern is in the right place
wow
no reaching
no changing the shape
okay so
get on
shoot on goes right into
the next inverse spiral
on the head on the head back
so
very sophisticated martial principles
are in your wazzup but
you know
it's a thing of japanese culture to
make something profound
least from our perspective appear
overly simple
it kind of hides things in plain sight
okay you can't see them because because
you're looking for complexity
you're looking for
wow
and uh
japanese culture like wow is
it's not wild of them
scotty
okay it's unnatural it's force
okay so your aikido
is follow suit okay
um let's say
we're here
right and i don't know he does some
strike
okay so i come here and everyone would
recognize an inward parry
and then uh
everyone will recognize a check you see
the check
so he does that strike again
everyone's gonna go ah yeah
check and strike check and strike
okay
your keyhole has checks in it
but you don't see them
okay
so when we were just doing the
yesterday's technique so i'm doing uh
a jojo and here's that same check
there's that chest
right right here
okay
the reason you don't see the check
is because you want to
you want to use the arm
you want to use the arm without turning
do you get it
but really what you're doing is what
on
unchecking
do you get it
and other artists that do open check
training they're never gonna give this
check to
do this
especially as a knife for example he has
a knife i'm not going to come and try to
get this because he's going to stab me
with it
i would check in
maybe replace the check
i wouldn't ever
move the blade back towards me
you get it
so we're doing
uh
joedon
in this check is here
no i in my kazushi
took his arm off to check
i didn't take my check off his arm
and now the check has an offensive
purpose
so watch watch what i do okay
the check is there
not using the check for the position
his arm is now
no need in check because it's been
checked by the kazushi
so now the arm is repurposed
okay
but i'm not going here
and
repurposing it myself because that's a
marginally inferior position
so now i'm doing we'll stay low
uh now i'm doing
chewed up
here's going to be the checking one
right there
i don't want to come underneath and
he'll hold me in the face
so i'm not going to come underneath and
hook you with my
fingers like some of you are again to do
the turning
right or worse
again you're dreaming you're unchecked
it's not going to happen
that's where the check is
but that's where the check stays until
guess what the kazushi
repurposes it
he comes up
it's right there
you see it's that little guy oh
so
we have a concept of control maintenance
i go from one control point to the other
control point before i replace the
control point so both the check
and the kazushi are on at the same time
for a moment in time until the kazushi
takes over and then the check is no
longer needed
because she's checking the person
okay
again the reason you're doing it is
because you need
a push pull
to do the turn
you understand and you can't be the
center of the technique
and do a push-pull you have to think
about that one okay it's not possible if
you're in the center of the technique
uh you're either pushing or you're
pulling but you can't do a pull that if
you do a push pull the center is
somewhere between you
do you get that
okay
so
a hair oh
and this hand stays there checking there
won't tell it's not needed then it's
repurposed
the other way you can think about it is
the sword
if our swords are touching you're not
going to take your sword off of mine and
try to come around i'm going to cut this
out of you right
okay you're just taking advantage of it
and it's king on
and there's no blades and stuff like
that but
again if i don't understand the martial
principles i should just do what my
teacher is doing until i do okay